when someone turns on a video they are
very quickly judging people on two
traits warmth and competence those are
the two most important traits in all of
our communication a lot of creators go
for competence I certainly did the first
intro I recorded was like this ever
struggle with how to introduce yourself
I'm going to give you five quick ways
and a formula for how you can introduce
yourself to anyone it looked so boring
when I watched it back I was like oh my
God the verbal was good but I did not
have enough expressiveness so instead I
recorded it where I added in the actual
awkwardness I feel in that situation so
it would be like have you ever had that
really awkward situation where you have
to introduce yourself but you don't know
how and it immediately added warm to the
video so it's not just smiling it's any
kind of facial expressiveness